شكرًا لك ،
إنه خدش الرأس ، كيف انتهى المطاف
ببومة ثلجية تعيش عادةً في
التندرا القطبية الشمالية وسط أشجار النخيل
في جنوب كاليفورنيا ، أعتبر أنه
لشرف كبير أن أكون قادرًا على رؤية
عشاق الطيور يتدفقون إلى Cypress
California للحصول
علىهدية
هذا مثير للغاية ، أرى طائرًا
لا ينتمي إلى هنا ، حسنًا ،
الجميع متحمسون لوجود كل هذه الغربان
التي كانت تغوص في قصفها
ومحاولة إخافتها بعيدًا
، ولم تكن البومة منزعجة تمامًا من أن الطيور
التي نشرت هذا  فيديو
يعترف نيكولاس بيلارديس بأنني مزقت
عالم أحياء بحرية قال لصحيفة نيويورك تايمز إن
الأمر أشبه برؤية سانتا كلوز على الشاطئ.
خبراء الحياة البرية يشاهدون البومة
مثل الصقر حتى إلى درجة
تسلق سلم لاستعادة
حبيبة قاتمة من قبل رابتور أوه
كنز على الفور تطرد الطيور
الأجزاء غير القابلة للهضم من وجباتهم ، لذلك قرر
مركز رعاية الحياة البرية والأراضي الرطبة
التحقق من طعم البوم في
مطبخ كاليفورنيا الذي يبدو مثل
جمجمة ، نعم ، انظر إلى جمجمة
نوع من القوارض ، فنحن نعرف ما أكلته ،
لكننا لا نعرف كيف وصلت إلى هنا ، هل هي
حيوان أليف غير قانوني هارب أم أنها
اصطدمت بسفينة شحن من أعلى الشمال أو
ربما حصلت للتو  مرتبكًا وطار
بعيدًا جدًا جنوباً ، يبدو لطيفًا ورقيقًا ،
أخبر هذا القارض الذي انتهى به الأمر
وكأنه قوس شعر ليس لطيفًا أو رقيقًا ،
دعنا نلقي نظرة أخرى على تلك الجمجمة
الرائعة
CNF New York